[Música]
y
bueno me gustaría que hoy
haya química entre nosotros y por eso
voy a contarles una historia de un viaje
en el tiempo que está sumergida y oculta
en la tabla periódica y los elementos
recuerdan esta tabla
muy bien es el resumen de las relaciones
que hay entre los elementos y sus
propiedades una inmensa fuente de
información
pero yo además veo en esta tabla miles
de años de investigaciones prácticas
oscuras y pasiones y cada elemento es
una historia como si fuese un libro cada
uno de los elementos naturales de la
tabla periódica fueron fabricados o
creados en inmensos hornos estelares
estrellas que murieron y explotaron para
dar vida en el tercer planeta del
sistema solar este la tierra por lo
tanto todos ustedes pueden decir sin
temor a equivocarse que somos polvo de
estrellas
la química no es una ciencia abstracta o
aburrida es terriblemente pasional en
donde se entrecruzan historias de egos
envidias sangre derramada y muerte todas
esas historias que concluyeron en el
descubrimiento de cada uno de los
elementos naturales se mantuvieron
desconectadas e inconexas hasta que un
químico sucumbió ante la danza embrujada
de los elementos químicos si ustedes
creen que las cosas ocurren por
casualidad escuchen esta historia
el 17 de febrero del año 1869 dimitri
ivanovic mendeleiev el gran químico ruso
intentaba desentrañar el problema de los
elementos químicos eran el alfabeto con
el que estaba escrito el lenguaje del
universo hasta ese momento se habían
descubierto 63 elementos químicos hoy ya
conocemos 118 mendeleiev era consciente
del significado de sus investigaciones
porque sabía que podían ser el primer
paso hacia el descubrimiento del secreto
último de la materia
aparentemente habían pasado tres días en
donde mendeleiev se había matado y se
había devanado los sesos en torno al
problema de los elementos químicos
tenían sobre su escritorio 63 tarjetas
en donde había escrito el nombre de cada
uno de los elementos químicos y trataba
de acomodar los de alguna manera sin
éxito como si estuviese jugando al
solitario pasaron dos o tres horas más y
abrumado momentáneamente por el
cansancio y el agotamiento mendeléyev se
inclinó hacia adelante apoyó su peluda
cabeza sobre sus brazos y casi de
inmediato quedó dormido y entonces tuvo
un sueño
vamos a hacer una cosa vamos a dejarla
mendeleiev durmiendo y soñando por un
momento y comencemos por lo fundamental
que es la química bueno la química es la
ciencia que estudia la composición la
transformación las propiedades y la
composición de la materia y como todo es
materia todo es química o la química
estas todas partes sólo tienen que mirar
a su alrededor a mí me gusta afirmar que
los elementos químicos tienen
personalidad carácter defectos y
virtudes como nosotros y si los
conocemos bien podemos decirles qué es
lo que tienen que hacer
podemos darle órdenes un químico maneja
el mundo a nivel atómico y molecular con
versatilidad
a mí me gusta jugar con los elementos le
voy a proponer un par de jueguitos para
que no digan que la química es tan
aburrida
miren podemos armar frases basadas en
las propiedades reales de los elementos
químicos
por ejemplo el té luro afecta el sistema
nervioso central el americio es muy raro
de encontrar pero el oxígeno nos
mantiene vivos así que pueden decir que
el amor es pura química está bien
[Aplausos]
otro juego a ver si les gusta cómo
lucirían los elementos si fuesen
personas
vamos a empezar por el oro que es el que
todos más queremos todos queremos al oro
no el oro es el más lindo es el más
bonito es maleable pero es poco sociable
no quiere reaccionar con nadie y eso es
porque es altanero debido a que es un
metal noble
en cambio el oxígeno admiran el oxígeno
es sometido está en todos lados quiere
reaccionar con todo el mundo es el
elemento más abundante de la superficie
terrestre pero es romántico y presumido
porque sabe que no podemos vivir sin él
está argón en cambio que está sentado
ahí atrás es tímido inactivo retraído
un vago para mí es un vago tiene un
grupo de amigotes el helio el neón el
xenón y el crypton igualitos a él les
decimos gases raros o inertes
el carbón o el carbón o decididamente
necesita un psicólogo tiene personalidad
bipolar puede ser un tipo blando y
quebradizo y entonces le decimos grafito
o puede ser el tipo más duro del mundo y
entonces es un diamante pero en el fondo
es un tipazo porque todo lo vivo depende
de él por último cuidado con el flúor
encabeza una banda llamada los halógenos
un grupo de ladrones de electrones y si
ustedes tienen electrones por ahí y
tienen miles y miles de millones de
electrones cuidado con este grupo de
elementos bueno basta de juegos sigamos
con las historias para qué sirve la
química mira estoy tentado de decir para
casi todo desde que nos despertamos
estamos en contacto con la química y la
vamos a encontrar en todo lo que nos
rodea todo está de hecho de sustancias
químicas los seres humanos estamos
hechos de sustancias químicas sus perros
también los escritorios las butacas en
donde están
el cielo la tierra los árboles la ropa
que tienen puesta la comida todo está
hecho de sustancias químicas la química
es la base de la medicina porque los
seres humanos a través de reacciones
químicas podemos crear medicamentos para
un amplio espectro de enfermedades para
que tengan una idea en el siglo 19 la
expectativa de vida era de más o menos
45 años en el siglo 20 pasó a ser de 75
aproximadamente y en el siglo 21 como ya
escuchamos se espera que la expectativa
de vida llegue a los 100 años y quién
sabe cuántos años va a vivir la especie
humana dentro de dos o tres siglos bueno
ahí está la química porque los
medicamentos los antibióticos las
vacunas los citotóxicos para el cáncer
el agua potable la nanotecnología hacen
todo esto posible
ahora que saben un poco más de química
sigamos con las historias
qué fue qué dilema existencial de
mendeleiev durmiendo y soñando recuerden
que lo tenemos examen de leyes durmiendo
y soñando
es decir cómo nació la química para eso
los invito a un viaje en el tiempo les
gusta viajar en el tiempo acompáñenme
vamos primero a la grecia antigua'
el primer ejemplo de un pensamiento
auténticamente científico es atribuir lo
actuales de mileto que vivió en el siglo
6 antes de cristo hace dos mil
seiscientos años cuenta la leyenda que
tales le gustaba a pasear por las
colinas que daban al mar egeo en mileto
mientras caminaba por las faldas que
bordeaban las colinas vio en unas rocas
unos fósiles de lo que alguna vez habían
sido caracoles marinos comprendió
entonces que esas colinas alguna vez
habían sido parte del mar
entonces infirió que en algún momento
todo había estado formado por agua y
concluyó que el agua era el elemento
fundamental del que estaba formada todas
las cosas podían cambiar de estado y de
forma podría ser gaseoso e invisible
podría ser líquido y fluido podría ser
sólido y rígido era como decían los
filósofos griegos el arte el principio
del universo el primer elemento de todas
las cosas es un pensamiento de hace dos
mil seiscientos años
por lo tanto yo les pido que le demos un
aplauso a tales
muchas gracias por tales
por este motivo tales de mileto es
considerado el primero de los filósofos
y su pensamiento es considerado también
el primer ejemplo de un pensamiento
genuinamente científico ya no había que
recurrir más a los caprichosos y
frívolos dioses del olimpo para explicar
los cambios en la naturaleza así como
tales había propuesto al agua como
primer y único elemento un par de siglos
después otro filósofo griego
empédocles proponía la teoría de los
cuatro elementos al agua le sumaba el
aire la tierra y el fuego y en la misma
época leucipo proponía la idea del átomo
no escucharon la idea del átomo tiene
dos mil cuatrocientos años los logros
del más grande filósofo griego
aristoteles
marcaron el curso del desarrollo
científico hasta bien entrada a la edad
moderna para aristóteles que se la sabía
todas tenía que existir un quinto
elemento razonando que el agua la tierra
el aire y el fuego eran elementos
terrenales y corruptibles y que las
estrellas no podían estar hechas de
ninguno de ellos sino de otro diferente
al que llamó éter o quinta esencia
el modelo del aristotélico resultó
perfecto cerraba por todos lados y la
tierra se convirtió en el centro del
universo
y como todo aparentemente estaba hecho
el pensamiento científico se detuvo por
casi 2000 años dejando el terreno libre
para el desarrollo de la alquimia y del
oscurantismo
por esos tiempos en egipto hagamos otro
salto en el tiempo más precisamente en
la fabulosa alejandría el pensamiento
griego se topó con una forma de
conocimiento mucho más antigua llamada
arte egipcio o que mejía los orígenes de
la que medida se pierden en la noche de
los tiempos y los practicantes de la que
media eran considerados magos o brujos
entonces los griegos dieron el nombre de
genia al arte de tratar los materiales
con el objetivo de cambiar su naturaleza
luego cuando los árabes invadieron a
egipto en el siglo 7 entre muchas cosas
que hicieron pusieron el prefijo al a
muchas palabras y la chen ya pasó a ser
alquimia y luego alquimia que perduró
por 18 siglos
dentro de la alquimia paso de todos los
alquimistas hicieron miles de
experimentos y reacciones químicas en
sus oscuros y escondidos típicos
laboratorios con el objetivo principal
de transformar los metales bajos en oro
cosa que nunca consiguieron porque es
imposible
la transmutación de los metales bajos en
oro la piedra filosofal el elixir de la
juventud eterna y la teoría del flogisto
son los paradigmas de la alquimia sin
embargo los cerebros de los alquimistas
y sus prácticas químicas terminaron
conformando un cuerpo de conocimiento
científico que complementaba al de los
filósofos hoy de ser necesario no los
podemos arreglar sin la filosofía pero
no sin la química y vamos a la última
escala de nuestro viaje
francia siglo 18
antoine laurent del agua ciega es
considerado el fundador y el padre de la
química moderna refutó empíricamente la
teoría del flogisto y desde los 5
elementos y principios aristotélicos
nada se pierde todo se transforma no es
una canción del cantautor uruguayo jorge
drexler bueno si es una canción es una
linda canción hermosa canción pero antes
antes fue la famosa ley de la
conservación de la materia enunciada por
la o asier que derrumbó a la alquimia
para dar paso a la química como una
ciencia exacta
el agua si era un apasionado de la
química y por eso se pocas se avecina va
la revolución que comenzó con aquel
recordado 14 de julio de 1789 con la
toma de la bastilla
pero la estupidez humana es infinita
escuchen esto
la vacía y estaba casada con la hija del
dueño de la empresa que recauda de
impuestos en francia motivo por el cual
fue acusado de recaudador de impuestos y
arrestado en el año 1793
a pesar de su brillante mente científica
de todos los aportes dados a la química
a la ciencia y principalmente a francia
la uaz y fue condenado a muerte y
guillotinado el triste 8 de mayo de 1794
a la edad de 50 años pero su legado
había quedado había sepultado
definitivamente a la alquimia para dar
paso a la química
desde la filosofía griega pasando por la
alquimia medieval hasta la decisión del
átomo se puede trazar la historia del
nacimiento de la química y del papel que
desempeñaron el sueño de muchos hombres
y mujeres
recuerdan que teníamos a medio durmiendo
y soñando finalmente despertó
y sus palabras fueron las siguientes en
un sueño vi una tabla donde todos los
elementos se encajaban en su lugar
cuando desperté tomé nota de todo en un
papel aquí pueden ver la tabla original
manuscrita por mendeléyev cuando
despertó de su dulce sueño mendeleiev en
un sueño había comprendido que si se
alistaban los elementos en orden
creciente de sus pesos atómicos sus
propiedades se repetían en una serie de
intervalos periódicos
por este motivo llamó a su
descubrimiento tabla periódica de los
elementos habían transcurrido una gran
cantidad de intentos fallidos pero una
gran pasión lo había conducido a uno de
los descubrimientos más importantes para
la química y para la ciencia había
clasificado los ladrillos con lo que
estaba construido el universo
lo que me del ayer descubrió aquel 17 de
febrero de 1869 es la culminación de una
obra épica de 2500 años de duración una
voluntariosa parábola de las
aspiraciones humanas la tabla periódica
es nuestro icono el de los químicos
porque es lo que todos relacionan con la
química
en el año 1955 se descubrió el elemento
químico 101 que inmediatamente y
naturalmente ocupó su lugar en la tabla
periódica recibió el nombre de mende le
vio en reconocimiento al supremo logro
de mendeleiev
muy apropiadamente es un elemento
inestable igual que era mendeleiev y
proclive a la fisión nuclear espontánea
pasajeros hemos terminado el viaje
quedo contento y satisfecho porque estoy
seguro que hoy si entre nosotros hubo
química muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]